this morning the death of an American
teacher in the Dominican Republic is
being investigated as murder police say
they found Patricia Anton in her
apartment in Puerto Plata that's on the
country's northern coast her hands and
her feet were tied up
officials say the 63 year old woman was
strangled our national correspondent
Jericka Duncan is following this story
Jericka terrible news today are there
any leads on who may have done this to
her well good morning Gail police have
not yet indicated that there are any
suspects in this case but they've
revealed that Anton's death may be part
of a burglary
investigators say multiple items were
missing from her apartment including a
cell phone a laptop a television sheets
and a pair of sports shoes Patricia
Antin hailed from Michigan and dedicated
her life to helping children she was a
consultant at an elementary school in
the DR and has lived there for at least
five years the school's website says she
had more than 20 years of teaching
experience and was previously a
legislative aide at the Michigan State
Capitol anton is one of at least 11
Americans who died in the DR this year
the rest have been tourists and the
reasons range from natural causes to
deaths possibly linked to tainted
alcohol now Anton's body will now be
taken to a lab in Santiago City for
further testing police are urging anyone
with knowledge of the crime to come
forward we have reached out to the State
Department for comment but have not
heard back
Tony some troubling details there's Rica
thank you very much